Bardéla is elected president of the national restaurant
Bardéla succeeds Marine Le Pen
at the head of the national gathering
far right party
he was widely elected by rn members
with nearly 85
votes on November 5
at 27 years old he has comfortably imposed himself
in front of the mayor of Perp
louis aliot who collected only 15
16 of the votes
much appreciated by members
Charles Bardella was the favorite
thanks in particular to his background in the party
native of drancy in seine saint denis
Bardella
grew up in a family of Italian origin
he is 16 years old
when he joined the national front in February 2012
the ancestor of the national gathering
and in about ten years
he quickly climbs the ladder
under the leadership of marine le pen
good little soldier
he goes through the positions of party secretary
of spokesperson
then director of Generation Nation
the orn youth affiliate movement
then
he becomes a leader in the European elections
and takes the interim presidency
during the presidential marine campaign le pen
although he is close to the family circle
he is the first one who does not have the name le pen
to assume the presidency of the rn because before him
it was marine le pen and his father jean marie le pen
who held the reins of the party